[Music]
hey
here we are it's wednesday yeah
i totally forgot to wish happy birthday
to sophie yesterday yeah you did i
i said i i thought it i thought it was
today you're [ __ ] tripping
i don't know what day it is it's like a
trip i mean i kind of know what day it
is she's been busy she's been she's been
really quick
cracking the whip on herself like always
that sounded dirty
[Laughter]
yeah so uh this movie we're talking
about today this kind of just came
out of nowhere didn't it yeah yeah she
she put it on netflix and we
we finished up watching the damn what
are you watching unsolved mysteries
because yeah like i said we only had one
more uh episode of that yeah and as we
as when we first clicked in it showed an
ad for this and i was like tremors
and it had the uh it had a picture of
the dude that was from um
that crazy looking dude use it for mandy
remember he played the [ __ ] kids
richard brake i think that guy's name is
he wasn't wasn't he in like
the new rob zombie movie and yeah i
think he was i think he's in hannibal
rising and stuff
he's a cool dude he always plays like a
crazy [ __ ] yeah i think he's
european and he
oh you know what i don't know i don't
even think he said no i don't think so
okay all right i think he's american
anyway uh
i saw that dude's face and i was just
like tremors
they still make those yeah and i was
like we gotta see it you clicked it on
and right off the bat it was [ __ ]
awesome they were
what a fun movie yeah it was so fun they
were
immediately homaging um predators
and kong skull island and they knew they
were
homos in it it was it was pretty funny
you know it's good it's a it's a good
action movie with suspense in it with
elements of horror and a lot of and
comedy
yeah with a good script and uh
it just i think i've only seen like the
first three tremors movies i might have
only seen
the first one and maybe one like the
fifth
yeah or something like another one like
in the middle somewhere
it was okay look i don't know spoilers
you know this is gonna this is the last
one
all right and they give they give this
the series a good send-off in this
yeah it looks like it's gonna be the
last yeah i mean it might not be i don't
know might not be but it's probably the
last one mark says ass blasters
yeah talk about it this is a new kind
and
there's a new kind of monster in this
one it's kind of like a mutation of
some of the other ones and i seem to
remember from watching the old ones
every time
every time the movie comes out there's
some new ones there's some new graphics
because it's evolving
yeah because they're evolving like so
it's bigger because they always have to
like up the ante you know
every single time script is good edit
was tight
tone was [ __ ] spot-on
uh good classical score and it
you know it was up there with like
predator this movie looked like it cost
a lot of money it's expensive yeah i
mean it really did it's taking place on
an island that
this obviously they're ripping off skull
island and [ __ ] but
the whole movie's ripping off other
movies it's just it's just giving you
what you wanted
well and the guy and one of the
characters even references predator
like yeah yeah movie yeah they're not
they're an evil dead
and evil and it's kind of making call
backs to the older movies some of the
cheesiest special effects and the old
moves like how they blow up it just
looks like damn
gelatin that comes down they do that or
they blew up a watermelon like it was a
yeah
or something so it's homage in the
series
and uh staying true to to the lore of
the series
it's just it's just a fun movie to watch
it was actually it was so funny because
i didn't realize so this
is because i knew they were still making
tremors movies because like i said the
first one
it seemed like it didn't do very well at
the box office but then like later it
kind of got this huge cult following so
they just kept making them
and i was like because when we first
started it i was like
what i was like which one is this is it
six or seven it's actually seven this is
tremor
seven okay the sixth one came out in
2018
most of them are just gone straight to
to vod and straight to blu-ray like this
one did yeah so i think it came out on
blu-ray and
vod same day you know what this just
came out
yesterday that's why we didn't because
we had been watching netflix today when
i didn't see that
um and then so it came out so i looked
it up and they're like yeah it only just
hit the platform
yesterday and that's why we just saw it
i remember really enjoying the first two
when they came out i saw the very first
one in the theater
everybody loves the first one i mean the
first one's so [ __ ] good first first
two were good
i think i remember seeing the three
three you know part three it was okay
and i didn't see any in any of them
after that
you don't have to see them all if you've
seen the first two
it's good enough you know you know what
you know what the series is about
i mean i feel like if you do know
something about the series like
obviously you're gonna get a lot more
out of it because this one
you know referenced back to a lot of
stuff from the other from the other ones
and i haven't seen all the other movies
i've only seen like two or three of the
other ones
but i knew enough that i could kind of
like even if i didn't know exactly what
they were imagining i knew that they
were homaging something yeah from back
then
and uh yeah and michael gross is in this
playing uh
mr gummer bert gummer yeah bert did
celebrate bird cummer day on april 14th
or whatever it was and said at the end
yeah that's like so [ __ ] funny is
that a real thing i guess it must be you
can make any kind of day you want
but yeah so basically the story of this
like i said i don't remember i don't
think i saw the sixth one so i don't
know
um what happened with that one but i
guess there's
they've been like um [ __ ] what do you
do like uh
like genetically like [ __ ] with the
with the graboids or whatever
yeah so i guess the setup for this is
that richard brake's character
is he has this private island where he
has bred
like some big huge graboids like like
bigger than the other ones
they're the size of a dam almost like a
[ __ ] sand worm from [ __ ] auracus
they're always one of them they're
really they're really pretty big
so um yeah so he's bred like four of
them on this
island so that he can like um get all
these
like rich people to come and hunt them
you know what i mean
um but of course you know
he tried he's doing that and then like
[ __ ] goes awry
uh you got your shriekers uh it's called
shrieker island by the way uh
this movie and uh also you have like
somebody if there aren't any ass
blasters in this are there
no they were trying they had to kill
them before they turned into [ __ ]
and first before they turned it down
because they might escape the island the
special effects are really good
um there's a mixture of cg and practical
effects yeah
the cg looked really good show slow
motion shots of the damn grab woods
coming up out of the ground
spinning with their jaws open as they
were going like a damn
spinning drill bit yeah it looked really
cool
yeah look good i mean it's pretty it's
it's pretty gory but i think
that it's pg-13 so it's not that gory
although it was i didn't really notice
that it wasn't super gory because like
some of the effects and like the monster
and stuff looked like what
what impressed me is that this is the
last of the movie and it's probably the
best ones in terms of execution and
special effects the first
two i remember were really good uh with
the special effects this one still
looked better
it looked like uh this was on par with
[ __ ] kong skull island almost
it did i was like really like when it
first came on i was like wow they spent
some [ __ ] money on this
yeah like the cinematography like where
they shot it it looked like gorgeous the
score
it sound was like i was like is this
this is like [ __ ] lord of the rings
god damn i was like look at this [ __ ]
yeah it was like a big budget
blockbuster
it was that's i should have looked up
like how much it costs to make because
it looks like really expensive
it looked like you said it looked like
kong's got a lot it looked like that
same kind of
same kind of deal like uh you know look
to it definitely worth watching
yeah and it's like like i said i love
the [ __ ] all the characters are funny
there's a bunch of characters but it
doesn't really matter they're all like
pretty
memorable and uh there's a lot of funny
lines and i love the guy
um the one guy who's like a research
scientist or whatever the one that wears
the hawaiian shirt all the time that
dude's super funny yeah cause he's just
like this
he's like real dorky but then he kind of
like you know bands up at the end and
it's like really funny and like
obviously michael gross is [ __ ] great
in all of these yeah and there's these
different groups of hunters out hunting
them and each hunter is different got
their own specialty
and it's homage and um predators
yeah they have different kinds of
badasses even got to do with a minigun
you know they got they got this one
black chick she's kind of dressed up and
do uh like the
like uh the new laura croft a little bit
with a bow but she was kind of wearing
laura croft's outfit
you didn't notice yeah it was very
similar to that yeah with the blue top
and the [ __ ] shorts and everything
she's amazingly lean that woman yeah she
was
you're second thin man yeah
now i kind of wish that we had seen i
kind of feel like recently
didn't we watch another tremors movie
like the fifth one or the sixth one i
can't remember
but i don't know if you finished that i
think that might have been a couple of
years ago
it was okay well the sixth one came out
two years ago
was it yeah so maybe it was that one
maybe it was i just remember that it was
just okay
yeah i remember being like oh that was
all right i mean i feel like this one
was like way way better yeah way better
yeah
i got like a lot more this one actually
you know technically i think might have
been better than the first one
well from a filmmaking standpoint
certainly yeah i mean it
looked a lot more expensive it looked a
lot more professionally done like like i
said it looked like a big budget
yeah movie yeah like the way it was
pretty good with the sky
and everything you know they were also
kind of doing a little bit of a jurassic
park thing too yeah yeah yeah yeah
like jurassic park was there was there a
jurassic park that was set on an island
i only saw the first one jurassic park
was kind of set on an island well yeah
that's true
and uh remember sorry yeah i saw the
first one a long time ago that's about
it
the rich guy was going to charge people
to come to the island same idea
yeah to see these things but they were
going to haunt them yeah so it's the
same kind of thing so they're going to
haunt it but then
there's like another island that's not
that far away that has like a research
team
like scientists on it and of course
they're freaking out because they're
like now this
now they're it's like an invasive
species and you've read them over here
yeah they were genetically engineered
kind of like the dinosaurs
yeah yeah so it it was a it's kind of
homage in that too
yeah i guess it was time but like i said
i don't even remember because
i know we saw one recently and it
probably i it must have been five or six
five or six now wasn't it tremors
bloodlines or whatever that was
something like that
that was the fifth one okay because the
sixth i don't remember what the sixth
one was called but i'm pretty sure that
that wasn't it i think
bloodlines was the fifth one and i
remember not loving that one but it was
like
pretty good so i don't know if the whole
like um
you know genetically enhanced graboid
thing i don't know if that's been
referenced before or if that's like a
new thing
you know what i'm saying because i don't
know a huge amount about the franchise
um but yeah i mean if you really like
the tremors franchise then there's
probably no reason why you wouldn't like
this one because
it's super fun and it's just like a big
adventure out on an island with big
[ __ ] monsters and it's super cool
yeah and um so also also when i say too
that we finally watched the uh
the last episode of unsolved mysteries
which we didn't talk about yesterday um
that [ __ ] right there okay so this
episode was lady in the lake right
this happened in 2000 what did i want to
say 2010
it was like fairly recently um and it
was this
the woman in michigan
they found her car parked in front of
the church and then like they found like
a
footprints and butt prints like in the
snow like everybody's frozen river and
then they couldn't find her
that's where she scooted down into the
river except i don't think that's what
happened
i think somebody jumped and pulled a gun
on her and told her to get down in that
water
well you know you know what is makes me
think that maybe not though
is that one a according to witnesses
because she left the church she was out
like some because she was a catholic and
she was at some kind of church thing
and a bunch of people were there and
they saw her now her car was there
and then a bunch of people that were
coming out of the church they said well
then her car wasn't there there was no
car there but then her car was there
later
and like her uh purse was still in it
but not her cell phone or anything
so whoever like did something to her
moved her car at some point like took
her somewhere in it and then
brought the car back and parked it there
i kind of feel like that's what happened
i don't think that she went into the
river at that spot
because even though they did find her
body later
like many many months later it was like
35 miles away
and it was in the water but
i don't think that there was any like
the the where she was supposedly
went into the water like across the
street from the church was frozen
mostly and there was no um current
so i don't think if she'd just gone into
the water and drown i don't necessarily
think that
her body would have been carried that
far you know what i'm saying and because
like they knew that she disappeared and
then they were looking for
like for days and days and they couldn't
find her so i feel like they would have
found her because the
[ __ ] [ __ ] was full of ice though
all right sure they saw her her car
wasn't there
then she came back later on yeah and i
think somebody
knew who she was and or maybe just tried
to rob her or something
there was some kind of a vendetta pulled
a gun on her
but she tried to get away from the guy
she went to the water and he started
maybe shooting at her or threatened to
shoot her
and she scooted off into the water yeah
it was cold
all right so you don't need strong
current the the uh
hypothermia will kill you pretty quick
you don't have to drown
well yeah but i was frozen but i'm
saying that how did her body get that
far away from like where they found it
it just counts
it was a long time after you know i mean
it's plenty you know 35 miles three
months you know sure it could drift
but i for sure do not believe because it
seemed like the cops and they even
showed like the interviews with the cops
and everything like that
it seemed like the cops were just like
yeah she like just scooted into the
water and killed herself i'm like i
don't think it was suicide no i don't
think it was either i think somebody
murdered her i'm not saying that she
didn't go in the water there i don't
really think she did i think somebody
drove her someplace and dumped her like
farther up the river
but i got a feeling that hold on
somebody at the door i think that um
yeah
but i definitely think she got murdered
i don't think that that was suicide
and to be honest with you i think the
cops
were kind of like they just decided that
it was suicide like to start with and
they were just like man we're just not
going to investigate anymore
they didn't like do they didn't even do
like basic [ __ ] they didn't even do
like um they didn't do like getting
fingerprints off of her purse which was
like still
in the car like her purse was ripped
like somebody had kind of maybe grabbed
it or tried to grab her or whatever
they didn't do anything about that um
basically all they said was that
um there were some fingerprints in the
car but they were too smudged to be of
any use and it just seemed like they
didn't even really want to investigate
any further
they're just like yeah she just walked
into the water and killed herself and
like case closed
but i kind of agree with the family on
this one that i think somebody killed
her
now they tend to think that it was maybe
somebody that was in the family because
there were some like motives
for that um i don't know if that's the
case it could have just been
random um but i mean i don't think it
was a mugging necessarily because i
don't they
didn't take her purse i don't think they
took anything out of it but
i definitely do think that she was
murdered that's for sure
just saying um all right so you done
talking
yeah what was the cause of death though
there was did they ever really
decide she was by the time they found
her she was too um yeah
decomposed i bet you hypothermia they
were too uh
she got into freezing cold water and it
doesn't take long few minutes
yep that's what i think happened i think
somebody chased her off into the water
that's for sure that's possible she ran
off into the water to get away from
somebody
because they like the shoes she had on
they were like that would be really dumb
to just like walk
because they showed like somebody in the
same shoes yeah but that's
not dumb when somebody's pointing a gun
well no i'm just saying she wouldn't
have done it yet she would have done a
volunteer that's what i'm saying yeah
i definitely don't think she killed
herself like the cops said i think so
she saw something somebody threatened
her and she i think she
tried to get away from the person or or
the person
ordered her to [ __ ] jump in the water
yeah at gunpoint it's just
difficult to say it's a weird difficult
to say weird case but yeah so if you
haven't watched unsolved mysteries uh
you know go watch those like it's six
episodes they're all like actually
really good
the only one i wasn't crazy about was
kind of the tsunami one just because it
was kind of
all over the place and you know the
paranormal ones aren't as interesting to
me as the true crimes are
just you know my own personal opinion
and also
like i said if you like monster movies
and you like the tremors series
i didn't even know there was gonna be a
seventh tremors movie came out but
there it was like right there on netflix
they just added it yesterday
so uh you should go watch that too get
get some booze
get some snacks sit down and watch the
monster movies
it's super fun and uh you'll be really
into it okay so
that'll do it for our matinee today uh
we're not gonna stream again until
saturday uh for our main episode so uh
tomorrow you can watch the witching hour
friday you can watch our movie review
jair says that people that he's not
getting notifications about the shows
going up either
you sure you did you sure you clicked
the bell
yeah you gotta make sure make sure you
click i mean now i have been
kind of strapped like uh like i'll i put
a message up like on youtube community
and stuff like for the main shows but i
kind of stopped doing it for matinee
because i was like look we everybody
knows we're going we're doing a matinee
yeah at three o'clock like you know
sunday monday tuesday wednesday
so it seemed dumb for me to have to just
go and like announce it every time i'm
like you know you guys figured out
but um i'll usually put up something on
saturdays then i'll say
like a few hours before and i'll say
that we're going up and what the topic
is
but that's about it so i don't know if
that's what you meant just gotta
resubscribe he's not getting
notifications uh that that the
the shows are going up on youtube so you
know okay so look at pookie just running
in here
oh no pal here i come okay go ahead and
sign up
all right all right we're gonna go we'll
see you guys
later bye